what about you
sorry
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go
i always wanted to be part of something
bigger
i love that answer something that lasts
that means something something more
important than life yes
[Music]
it's written in the stars i am a star
if i had money i would only spend it on
things that were fun you know not boring
things like taxes i'm just waiting for
everyone to party forever
[Applause]
when i first moved to l.a signs on all
the doors said no actors are dogs
allowed i changed that
and now
y'all ready for something different
whoa
you know we have to do we have to
redefine the form
map those dreams and print them into
history look up and say
eureka i'm not alone
get it
i'm in so much trouble manny
we have to live now
what i do means something
you thought this town needed you
it's bigger than you
it's the most magical place in the world
lift that up oh you big dick mr man who
wants to see me find a snake
[Music]